Okay, haben Sie auch eine offene Wunde bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Herr Meier, leiden Sie unter Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbern?
Ich habe keine, dieser wäschewerden Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Herr Meier, wie sieht Ihre Ernährung aus?
Ich meine, essen Sie häufig Fleisch, Meeresfrüchte oder Innereien?
Ja Doktor, ich esse immer Fleisch.
Ja, ich weiß, ich muss nicht viel Fleisch essen.
Ich bin Altermann, aber ich esse immer Fleisch, als Frühstück oder Gemüse oder Obst.
Okay, Herr Meier, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, ich hatte übrigens vor etwa einer Woche schon einmal ähnliche Beschwerden.
Auch in diesem Bereich oder anderen Geländen?
In diesem Bereich.
Okay, und haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden in einem anderen Ort gehabt?
Ich meine Kniegelenk, Handgelenk?
Nein, nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Immer in einem anderen Bereich.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe versucht, mit überprüfen, 400 mg, aber das ist nicht geholfen Doktor.
Okay, Herr Meier, sind Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich bin nicht anderes Arzt gewesen Doktor, nein.
Okay, alles klar. Leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe keine Dasebechwerden, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay, das freut mich. Herr Meier, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ja, ja, ich habe Fieber, ja, Sie haben recht Doktor.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Ja, gestern, ich habe gemessen, das Fieber ist 38,9.
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen? Im Mund, in der Achselhöhle?
Im Mund, in der Achselhöhle.
Okay, Schüterfrost und Nachtschweiß haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe Nachtschweiß, wegen dieser Schmerzen habe ich auch Schlafschleim.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide.
Okay, ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, ja, alles ist in Ordnung, ja. Aber Doktor, ich muss sagen, ich habe Sucherkrankheit.
Deswegen muss ich viele Mal häufiger in die Toilette gehen, besonders in Nacht.
Okay, wie viele Mal müssen Sie in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen?
Drei oder vier Mal.
Okay, alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, aber seit zwei Tagen habe ich kaum Appetit.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe nicht gewirkt, Doktor.
Okay, sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Super. Herr Meyer, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Reise, besonders eine lange Reise gemacht?
Lange Reise? Was ist in der letzten Zeit?
Ja, ich meine vor dieser Beschwerden.
Ah ja, ich verstehe. Nein, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Meyer, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie an Sucherkrankheit leiden seit wann?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme dagegen mit vor mir 8.750 mg täglich morgens.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe außerdem Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann?
Seit langem, ungefähr zehn Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie ein Medikament dagegen ein?
Ja, dagegen nehme ich April 10 mg Tablet eins. Und täglich eins Tablet und Lersanitipin 10 mg täglich einmal.
Lersanitipin 10 mg täglich immer morgens oder abends?
Einmal morgens und Lersanitipin abends.
Okay, alles klar. Sonst noch etwas?
Das war es, Doktor.
Okay. Herr Meyer, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche anderen Medikamente, außer genannten, ein?
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe Gallamblese entfernt bekommen.
Wann war das?
Vor zwölf Jahren.
Okay. Und sonst noch etwas?
Außerdem wurde mir nach einem Armfraktor eine Platte eingesetzt.
Ich hatte einen Fahrradunfall.
Oberarm oder Unterarm? Und welche Seite?
Oberarm, rechte Seite.
Okay. Wann war das?
Es war vor 20 Jahren, ja.
Okay. Alles klar.
Herr Meyer, sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente, Pflanzen, Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich bin gegen braunes Pflasterallergie, Doktor.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das äußert sich mit Rötung unter der Haut.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas oder Unfertigkeit haben Sie?
Ja, mit Produkten vertrage ich auch nicht gut.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Die fühlen sich bei mir zu Tuschfall.
Okay. Herr Meyer, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, Doktor.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein.
Super. Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich etwa eine Kiste Bier pro Woche.
Meinen Sie 20 Flaschen, oder?
Ja, eine Kiste.
Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich habe mit Kontakt mit Drogen keine Erfahrung, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich.
Herr Meyer, Sie sind jetzt 76 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Wohnen Ihre Eltern noch?
Leider, Doktor.
Okay. Woran sind Ihre Eltern verstorben? Darf ich fragen?
Meine Mutter hat Herzrhythmuskulstörungen und Darmkrebs gestorben.
Sie war 66 Jahre alt.
Und Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist mit 75 Jahren alt, mit einem Schlaganfall und einer Zuckerkrankheit gestorben.
Okay. Mein Beileid, Herr Meyer.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verfüttert, Doktor.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Herr Meyer, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe vier Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Drei davon leben und sind gesund, aber eines ist gestorben, Doktor.
Darf ich fragen woran ist Ihr Kind verstorben?
Ja, es war ein Unfall, Doktor. Autounfall.
Mein Beileid. Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne mit meiner Partnerin.
Okay. Sie sind jetzt Rentner, Herr Meyer, aber was haben Sie früher als Beruflich gemacht?
Ich bin jetzt Rentner, aber früher arbeitete ich in einer Firma Leiter.
Okay. Ich bedanke mich, Herr Meyer. Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich? Ersündung oder andere?
Ja, ich glaube Sie haben recht, Herr Meyer. Es ist zu früh etwas genau zu sagen, aber ich vermute, dass Sie an Gicht leiden.
Gichtanfall, ich meine. Aber wie gesagt, das ist nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen. Okay?
Welche Untersuchungen können Sie mir durchführen, Doktor?
Ja, ich werde eine Röntgenaufnahme machen und auch eine Ultraschalluntersuchung, Herr Meyer.
Eine Ultraschalluntersuchung ist eine Röntgenaufnahme oder, Doktor?
Genau, Sie haben recht. Eine Ultraschalluntersuchung ist sowohl schrallenfrei als auch schmerzfrei, Herr Meyer.
Wie lange dauert diese Untersuchung?
Etwa 20 Minuten.
20 Minuten?
Ja, genau. Damit können wir Ihr Knochen, Ihr Gelenkspalt genau beurteilen.
Wie gesagt, das ist völlig schmerzfrei. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Danke schön, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie, Doktor. Danke schön.
Okay, danke. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da. Okay?
Danke schön.
Gerne. Okay. Waschlörm habe. Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Wolfgang Meyer ist 76 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß und 95 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Meyer stellte sich bei uns wegen seit gestern bestehender rechtseitiger Sprunggelang Schmerzen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien drückend und würden in das rechte Knie und in die großen Zähne ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzkala mit 6 von 10 bewertet und die Einnahme von Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen bei Belastung und auch in Ruhe aufgetreten und die Hochlagerung hätte eine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Außerdem klagte der Patient über Erithem, Ödem und Kalor am rechten Sprunggelenk und rechten Waden.
Die Fragen nach Hypesthesie, Paresthesie, Verletzung, Alopezi, Nägelveränderungen, offene Wunde, Dyspnoe und Tussis wurden verneint.
Der Patient berichtete, dass er häufig mit Pyrin reiches Essen und Ernährung hatte und er hatte ähnliche Beschwerden vor einer Woche.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Pyrexie bis 38,9 C°
Er habe das Fieber in der Achselhöhle gemessen.
Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Anschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Nuktyrie 3-4 Mal in der Nacht. Schmerzbedingte Inapetenz.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-Infektionen geimpft und die Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 2 Jahren bestehenden Diabetes Melitis und seit 10 Jahren bestehende Arthöhle Hypertonie.
Er nehme mit Formin 850 mg morgens, Ende April 10 mg morgens und Lecarnedipin 10 mg abends ein.
Vor 12 Jahren sei bei ihm eine Cholocystektomie durchgeführt worden und vor 20 Jahren habe er sich eine Oberarmfraktur bei einem Fahrradunfall zugezogen,
die durch Platten behandelt worden sei. Er habe Allergie gegen Branuspflaster, die sich durch Erithem äußert und er habe Laktoseintoleranz, die sich durch Diarrhe.
Nikotinkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint und er trinke eine Kiste Bier pro Woche.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 75 Jahren an Apoplex verstorben sei.
Davor habe er an Diabetes Melitis gelitten. Die Mutter sei an Kolonkartzinom mit 66 Jahren verstorben und davor habe sie an Herzschlitzungsstörungen gelitten.
Er sei Einzelkind, verwitwet und habe vier Kinder. Drei Kinder sind gesund. Ein Kind sei bei einem Autounfall gestorben.
Der Patient wohne mit seiner Partnerin und er sei jetzt Rentner. Früher habe er als Leiter in einer Firma gearbeitet.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Arthritis Ulrica aus, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter rechtseitiger Sprunggelandschmerzen, Erithem, Kalor und er hatte ähnliche Beschwerden vor einer Woche.
Er hatte eine Arthritis Ulrica und er erwähnte, dass er häufig zu viel Fleisch und in der Reihen essen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Arthritis Ulrica. Als Differenzia-Diagnosen kommen Elisipel, TvT, Pavk und Chromatoid Arthritis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Erithem, Kalor, andere Hautveränderungen, wie zum Beispiel Allophezi, Nägelveränderungen, offener Wunde vorhanden sind.
Ich würde auch die peripheren Pulse abtasten. Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Handsäure, Chromatoidfaktor, CCS, Elektrolyten, D-Duma bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine zwei-ebenen Röntgen-Untersuchung des Sprunggelenks und Unterschenkelns durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Fraktur oder Handsäure-Kristallen, genau zu beurteilen.
Meinen Sie Gelenksonographie?
Ja, Gelenksonographie.
Ich würde gegebenenfalls eine MRT durchführen, um die weiche Gewebe-Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Bänderis, Benderuptur, genau zu erkennen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich eine Arthroscopie veranlassen, um die Struktur im Sprunggelenk genau zu beurteilen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und ich würde einen venösen Zugang legen.
Als akute Therapie würde ich Hochlagerung, Kühlung, Schulung, Korsischstherapie und gegebenenfalls Korsischstherapie verabreichen.
Auch Analytiker, wie zum Beispiel NSAR, würde ich verabreichen.
Danach würde ich ein orthopädisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Und für langzeitige Therapie würde ich Alloprinol verschreiben.
Und ich würde den Patienten Lebensstilveränderungen empfehlen, wie zum Beispiel Nikotinkarenz, Alkoholkarenz und Nahrungsstilveränderungen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberst.
Verstehe ich richtig. Der Patient raucht nicht. Aber empfehlen Sie Nikotinkarenz?
Ja, Sie haben recht, Herr Oberst.
Er trinkt viel Bier?
Also eine Kiste Bier bedeutet 20 Fleischbier pro Woche.
Das ist zu viel und Alkoholkonsum ist ein Risikofaktor bei der Artitis Ulrica.
Empfehlen Sie den Patienten fleischarme Ernährung?
Genau, fleischarme Ernährung. Pirinarme Ernährung würde ich dem Patienten empfehlen.
Wie können wir die Erdbeeren ausschließen?
Die Analyse ist sehr wichtig bei diesem Fall. Es gibt keine Verletzung, keine offene Wunderschicht.
Es gibt kein Risikofaktor bei dem Patienten. Aber er leidet unter Erithem und Kalor bei der rechten Waden.
Er leidet unter Fieber 38,9. Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Elisipel.
Es gibt ein Risiko für eine Elisipel. Ich würde zuerst die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall die Harnsäurewerte kontrollieren und danach würde ich vielleicht etwas über die Elisipel sagen.
Wie können wir die TvT und PavK ausschließen?
Bei dieser Erkrankung sollen wir eine Duplexonographie durchführen um die möglichen Gefäße und Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Können Sie uns die Duplexonographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über die Duplexonographie aufklären.
Die Duplexonographie ist eine besondere Untersuchung der Gefäße.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns die Durchblutstörungen, Sternose, Thrombose genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl schmerzfrei als auch strahlenfrei.
Wir sollen vorher die zu untersuchende Körperregion hier den Bein mit einem Gel einschmieren, damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Die Ultraschallwelle macht die Gefäße sichtbar und wir können die Gefäße auf einem Monitor sehen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20 Minuten. Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontaindikationen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es auch keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Arthroskopie des Schuprungedenkts?
Bei der Arthroskopie können wir Harnsäurekristallen feststellen.
Ansonsten können wir eine Sprunggelenk-Spaltverenkung feststellen.
Wir können eine Deformation in dem Sprunggelenk feststellen.
Würden Sie eine Eszernovialphilistik analysieren?
Auf jeden Fall. Wir können eine Sprunggelenk-Punktion durchführen, um die Eszernovialphilistik zu analysieren.
Was erwarten Sie bei der Sprunggelenk-Zonographie?
Bei der Sprunggelenk-Zonographie können wir Harnsäurekristallen feststellen.
Und auch Sprunggelenk-Deformationen feststellen.
Wie zum Beispiel Sprunggelenk-Spaltverenkung.
Würden Sie eine internistische Skonsüle anfordern? Und warum?
Das ist eine Stoffwechselstörung. Deswegen würde ich eine endokronologische Skonsüle anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Warum?
Artifice urica ist eine Art Stoffwechselstörung.
Das hat eine Verbindung mit Harnsäure Stoffwechsel.
Wir können auch eine Neuroinfizienz überprüfen.
Wie würden Sie eine Neuroinfizienz ausschließen?
Ich würde Harnstoffwerte und Creatininwerte überprüfen.
Zusätzlich würde ich auch Harnsäurewerte überprüfen, Herr Oberarzt.
Und?
Die Sonographie des Abdomens?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Sie haben recht.
Ich würde die Nieren genau beurteilen, ob es eine Nieren-Einschränkung gibt.
Oder?
Ergrößerung der Nieren.
Oder kleinere Nieren.
Erlauben Sie während der Therapie bei den Patienten zu laufen?
Meinen Sie Beweglichkeit?
Ja, Beweglichkeit.
Er ist 76 Jahre alt. Ich würde eine regelmäßige Beweglichkeit empfehlen, aber nicht zu viel.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt. Bitte gehen Sie in unser Info-Desk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikate.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihr Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt. Das war ein schönes und angenehmes Gespräch bei mir. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Wir haben keine Artilistik, keine Ürke, aber es geht immer um unsere Sachen.
Vorher, bei Krankheiten, bei Patienten, es geht immer um sie.
Siehst du in Ultrason Kristalle?
Sie sehen keine Kristalle in Ultrason, sondern sie sehen Knoten.
Sie können die leichten Töne sehen.
Sie können Kristalle in der Synabonial Analyse sehen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe es gerade gesagt, weil es in den Noten geht.
In Röntgen hat er gesagt, dass der Urat Kristall ist.
Du kannst in Röntgen Kristalle sehen. Du kannst Fraktoren machen, die du ausüben kannst.
Röntgen sind generell um die Körbe auszuschalten.
In Ultrason sieht man es nicht.
Das ist in den Knoten.
Das ist in Ksantin.
Das kann sein.
Das kann sein, aber es gibt keine Urukassid-Knoten.
Das ist eher in den Ecken.
Dann können wir Kristalle nicht in Ultrason sehen.
Du kannst Kristalle nur in der Synabonial Analyse sehen.
Ich bin nicht so witzig, weil ich das nicht so viel weiß.
Aber wenn du es willst, dann suche es dich.
Ich bin mir nicht verreizt.